those desserts going right ted yeah i'm
all desserts for thanksgiving
that's it how's the weather shaping up
for the big day well denise was asking
me is it going to be an outdoor thing
in a family and i just you know with the
winds probably not
i mean temperatures are going to be a
little on the chilly side too and
really it's thanksgiving like tomorrow
looks good it's just thanksgiving is
when we have all the big changes
great shot here looks like a painting
but it's our tower cam
catching that wonderful sunset again so
let's talk about rain right because
we just don't see it so today 218 days
now since we've had our last
measurable rainfall that was april 20th
again this is a record streak now
remember we're getting to december
and then that's it all right so next
month we have to get some rain in here
and we're definitely not going to catch
you up to our normal for this time of
year we'll show you that
in the next hour 58 degrees in sky
canyon along with centennial hill 60
even
for aliante the east side coming in at
64.
specifically for sunrise manor whitney
ranch in green valley you're at 62
henderson 59
mountains edge also 59 along with rhodes
ranch these numbers are right near
average that's going to change for
thanksgiving though along with wind
coming our way
prop at 63 for you 59 boulder city and
we're at 66 for laughlin
death valley checking in right now at 73
degrees so
clear here but that system yesterday
that brought us the wind
overnight and some showers around the
region not quite here but around the
region
there it is right now pivoting all the
way through kansas
brought some snow showers though in the
western portions the rockies here
earlier and that's good because remember
that feeds lake mead all the snow we get
on the western part of the rockies
feeds lake mead so we need the snow
there in the rockies
satellite radar as we look to the
northwest though this is the next system
that's impacting the area
as early as tomorrow we'll see a cold
front slice through tomorrow but it's
not really the cold front tomorrow
it's the winds behind that front that
we're going to see that it will
impact this by thursday now here's your
future cast there's
it's bringing rain in the pacific
northwest now but this is a moist
moisture starved system there's not a
lot of moisture with it as it tracks its
way down see this
not a lot probably some snow showers up
there in lincoln county
utah and also mohave county but we again
will remain dry we are confident though
that we are going to get winds for
thanksgiving now
hear your winds breezy winds early on
gusty midday
and at 3 pm maybe 4 p.m and by dinner
time those winds will decrease a little
bit but still remain
on the breezy side so here's your
forecast overnight
42 chilly and calmer we won't see those
winds as strong as we saw
earlier today and then your high
tomorrow 63 sunny and cool
and that puts us right near average at
least for one more day because by the
time thanksgiving comes
look at these numbers drop into the mid
to high 50s that includes black friday
too
and then look at that weekend looking
good first week of december
milder in those mid 60s too that's your
weather update just nobody
thanks so much ted